madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce dimanche 16
décembre
ils sont les premières victimes du froid
les sans abri sont au coeur d'une
nouvelle polémique entre les
associations de défense et la ministre
du logement
augustin legrand des enfants de don
quichotte et christine boutin se
répondre ce soir manque de logement ou
manque d'hébergement questions et
réponses
à suivre dans un instant les pilotes
judiciaire de la sphère de l'arche de
zoé est proche dans moins d'une semaine
les six français seront dans le box des
accusés alors que risque-t-il vraiment
reportage au tchad ce soir avec nous
également
les pousses de l'un des français retenu
n'djamena elle a été reçue hier par
nicolas sarkozy il faut parfois aider le
père noël et les adultes en savent
quelque chose c'est la dernière ligne
droite pour les achats des fêtes de fin
d'année un dimanche pas comme les autres
les tendances les coups de stress
reportage à suivre ce soir
laure manaudou n'est définitivement pas
une athlète comme les autres à la fois
dans le bassin et la compétition mais
également dehors son bilan aux
championnats d'europe deux médailles
d'or et une d'argent
et puis et puis du côté de la vie privée
une vie privée mouvementée interview
dans ce journal
enfin il n'a que 40 ans il est l'un
les acteurs les plus connus au monde
mais également l'un des plus brillants
d'hollywood
will smith n'en finit pas de nous
surprendre à l'écran il est le héros de
je suis une légende l'adaptation d'un
des plus célèbres romans de science
fiction il est l'invité de ce journal
bonsoir et à tout à l'heure
merci d'être avec nous ce dimanche soir
ce week-end aura donc été marquée par le
froid qui s'est installé sur l'ensemble
du pays et cette nuit les températures
seront à nouveau très froide regardons
la carte -7 degrés prévus à
clermont-ferrand - 5 à toulouse - 4 à
brest - 3° à paris alors avant de
revenir sur la polémique entre la
ministre du logement et les associations
de sans abri écoutons ce soir plusieurs
personnes qui souffrent au premier chef
de cette vague de froid propos
recueillis à paris et à quelques heures
par yann gicquel et david fossard alors
que christine boutin on dit il ya de la
place
il ya de la place pour tout le monde je
voudrais bien savoir si gyan il ya six
foyers habituels comme
nanterre - ou jours si vous voulez pas
dormir ou d'y aller quel est le problème
avec ces foyers
ces foyers ce qui vous fait un
constamment attention à ces affaires
parce que sinon vous ressortez où cette
impression d'abord font rentrer à telle
heure on sortira t heures c'est un peu
l'armé 1
on y parlait quand on est dix adultes et
c'est pas une solution parce qu impose
une solution à long terme
man et ses solutions à long terme
puisque effectué qu'à travers les
organismes sociaux
mais les moyens qui sont engagés qui
sont pas suffisants et ça vient du
gouvernement et de sa mauvaise volonté
dorothée cochard il n'y a pas de
personnes qui aient demandé un
hébergement en france cette nuit qui
n'est pas été hébergés ces paroles sont
celles de la ministre du logement
christine boutin elle répondait
aujourd'hui aux associations d'ados ou
sans abri qui lui réclament les moyens
promis l'an dernier à la même époque
bataille de chiffres querelle de mots
entre logement et hébergement chacun
avance son point de vue d'un côté ce
soir la ministre de l'autre augustin
legrand qui représente les enfants de
don quichotte yanncik elle philippe
turbo paris 14 heures la température
atteint péniblement les 2 degrés
derrière ces protections dérisoire des
hommes survivent et inévitablement entre
gouvernements et associations
la polémique enfle à propos de
l'efficacité du plan d'action pour
l'hébergement des sdf mise en place au
printemps dernier nombre de places
d'hébergement permanente a augmenté de
1300 depuis que je suis en charge de
cinq ministères c'est un mensonge d'état
que de dire aux français que les
objectifs sont tenues etc et don
quichotte et l'ensemble du milieu
associatif se trompent
au delà des chiffres il ya des hommes et
des dispositifs pas nécessairement
adaptée les quelques places qui doit
rester aujourd'hui sont des passes qui
sont indignes inadapté c'est des
dortoirs céder la place les gens ne
veulent pas dormir puisqu'ils ne peuvent
pas se reposer en sécurité savaient en
france on est très respectueux de la
liberté individuelle de chacun et celui
qui ne veut pas rentrer et on ne le ne
le force pas sauf s'il fait très très
froid et à son voile à olot glee il ya
un problème de survie le logement
d'urgence est une chose mais est ce que
la loi qui entre en vigueur le 1er
janvier répondre à la pénurie de
logements sociaux là en revanche les
inquiétudes sont partagées
le droit au logement opposable le juste
un droit c'est pas une politique du
logement à la les juges ne vont pas
construire ça va être 600 milles à 800
mille demandeurs pour soixante mille
logements du contingent préfectoral
c'est la réalité c'est le léger bug non
par la madame boutin c'est une
catastrophe pour les familles qui sont
en attente c'est une catastrophe pour
les sans abri et les personnes
concernées il manque des places de
maisons au lait il manque surtout des
constructions qui font que toute la
chaîne de logements et emboliser et que
c'est donc difficile et l'objectif est
de construire ce soir en france 33
départements restent au niveau 2 du plan
grand froid
devant la montée de la polémique le
premier ministre a décidé de prendre en
main le dossier et de recevoir mercredi
les associations d'entre aide
dans l'actualité de ce dimanche
également ce drame cette nuit dans un
pavillon de saint-aignan le jaillard
près d'orléans une famille a trouvé la
mort dans l'incendié de sa maison
c'est le fils aîné et qui a donné l'
alerte mais les pompiers n'ont pu éviter
la mort des quatre autres membres de la
famille récit arnaud compte
le pavillon a pris feu au rez de
chaussée vers 6 heures du matin pour une
raison encore inconnue un couple et
leurs trois enfants dormaient
voilà un petit problème de sujets au
tchad on s'oriente donc vers un procès
express à n'djamena dans la sphère de
l'arche de zoé qui aura été instruites
en un peu plus de 40 jours avant de se
retrouver devant la justice dès vendredi
prochain les six français seront dans le
box des accusés avant de retrouver dans
un instant les pousses de l'un des
prisonniers atmosphère au tchad avec
notre équipe amaury guibert et frédéric
franck dans n'djamena résonne toujours
les échos de la sphère de l'arche de zoé
un mois et demi après il est difficile
d'oublier surtout pour les mères de
famille comme jacqueline l'enfant tué
qui a conçu pendant neuf mois jusqu'à
élevé je ne dois pas vous
un peu plus loin dans une autre maison
du quartier la même incompréhension chez
ces deux heures on pourra pas accepté à
ce qu'on vienne ici à enlever nos
enfants tout le quel but
on ne fait jamais ça a choqué toute la
population connaît la colère ou pas je
crois que la situation est entre les
mains des juges mais les juges
travaille-t-il sereinement
rien n'est moins sûr depuis le début de
l' affaire certains magistrats dénoncent
des pressions politiques
une analyse partagée par sept avocats de
la défense ce facile de dire que mon
bain les autorités françaises ont mis de
la pression sur les autorités
tchadiennes de moi je dirais aussi l
inverse des autorités tchadiennes mettre
de la pression pour que la culpabilité
des gens de marque de l'arche de zoé
soit absolument retenu à l'est du tchad
là où à opérer l'arche de zoé les
conséquences de la sphère sont plus
profondes
toutes les organisations humanitaires
qui tentent de venir en aide aux
réfugiés du darfour ont subi le
contrecoup arche de zoé a créé un
problème additionnel qui a été la perte
de confiance complète de la part des
populations de fabienne il va falloir
qu'on recrée cette confiance
les 103 enfants eux sont toujours
retenus à l'orphelinat d'abéché est loin
de ces enjeux politiques humanitaires ou
judiciaires les parents qui ont été
identifiées attendre tout simplement de
pouvoir les récupérer et la mobilisation
des familles des membres de
l'association se poursuit ainsi
aujourd'hui à mourmelon-le-grand dans la
marne
plus d'une centaine de personnes lui ont
manifesté leur soutien et plus
précisément à l'un d'entre eux un impie
liga son épouse est avec nous bonsoir
christine kelly gars vous avez vendredi
en fin de journée rencontré nicolas
sarkozy est ce que les propos du
président de la république vous ont
rassurés sur l'issue de cette affaire
alors on a tout d'abord il y avait
monsieur sarkozy et monsieur kouchner
qui nous ont donc reçu au niveau de ces
propos ne sont bien affirmé que la
france ne les abandonnez pas maintenant
moi je suis toujours en grève de la faim
parce que j'attends j'attends de les
voir rentrer vous n'irez pas sur place
au tchad dans les prochains jours
non pour une bonne raison pour la
principale c'est que mes enfants estime
qu'il ya déjà papa qui est là bas et que
en deux par an les deux parents sur
place
les attroupements dit est-ce que vous
avez des nouvelles de votre mari qui a
lui aussi entamé une grève de la faim là
bas vous communiquer par mail je crois
on peut communiquer par mail et puis bon
h et la chance hier soir d'avoir le
médecin psychiatre qui a été dépêchée
par le quai d'orsay et qui a rencontré à
l'équipe et a pu me donner des nouvelles
et en particulier bien sûr de mon mari
vous êtes la maman de six enfants dont
trois adoptés au cambodge croix où se
tient à cueillir vous même au sein de
votre famille un de ses enfants
est ce que vous regrettez cette
opération de l'arche de zoé non en aucun
cas
en aucun cas je serais très de cette
opération à aucun moment vous êtes posé
la question
non non le but de cette opération
s'était sauvé des vies sauvées des
orphelins du darfour et je n'ai aucun
regret à nourrir aucun regret et qu'est
ce que vous attendez de cette décision
de justice
alors on fait que pour pour espérer une
éventuelle extradition il faut qu'en
effet il y ait une condamnation donc
j'attends qu'il y ait cette condamnation
et après de voir comment comment les
accords entre les deux pays vont pouvoir
fonctionner et permettre que l'équipe
rentre et permettre à votre mari de
rentrer en france
merci christine kelly ya en afrique en
somalie cette fois on a appris qu'un
journaliste français indépendant été
enlevés ce matin
gwen le gouil c'est son nom était arrivé
hier dans une région semi autonome du
nord-est du pays afin d'y effectuer un
reportage sur le trafic des migrants qui
traversent le golfe d'aden au yémen
le quai d'orsay vient d'indiquer qu'il
était en contact avec les possibles
ravisseurs dans l'actualité de ce
dimanche également ce drame donc cette
nuit dans un pavillon de saint-aignan le
jaillard près d'orléans
une famille a trouvé la mort dans
l'incendié de sa maison c'est le fils
aîné qui a donné l alerte
mais les pompiers n'ont pu éviter la
mort des quatre autres membres de la
famille récit arnault compte
le pavillon a pris feu au rez de
chaussée vers 6 heures du matin pour une
raison encore inconnue un couple et
leurs trois enfants dormaient à
l'intérieur à laitages le père est
réveillé par les flammes il crie pour
que tout le monde évacue seul l'aîné de
la famille parvient à s'extirper du
brasier en sautant par la fenêtre
ils alertent ensuite les pompiers à leur
arrivée ils les prennent en charge
immédiatement un jeune de 19 ans donc
qui avait pu lui sortir de l'habitation
qui nous fait part de la présence à
l'intérieur du reste de sa famille
mais à l'intérieur de la maison les
secours vont découvrir trois corps au
niveau de la cage d'escalier
le quatrième probablement celui de la
mer sera retrouvé un peu plus tard dans
ce village de 600 habitants où tout le
monde se connaît on est sous le choc
ce qui arrive aujourd'hui
les retourner la thèse de l'accident est
privilégiée par les enquêteurs
d'après les pompiers il pourrait s'agir
d'un défaut électrique l'habitation
n'était pourtant pas vétuste
ce sont des gens qui étaient installés
ici depuis le mois de septembre dernier
donc le dos puis récemment la maison
avait été rénové depuis l'année dernière
des gendarmes de l'institut de recherche
criminelle de rosny sous bois doivent se
rendre sur place demain pour déterminer
l'origine exacte de l'incendié
vous en souvenez peut-être il y a dix
jours un rafale s'est écrasé en corrèze
à neuvic exactement depuis les habitants
sont inquiets
la raison l'explosion de l'avion at elle
pu entraîner des risques réels pour la
santé la question a été soulevée pour
rassurer l'opinion
le site de l'accident et est ouvert
aujourd'hui aux médias et la population
explications jérôme berlin depuis jeudi
impossible d'approcher le site du crash
sauf pour ces militaires en combinaison
et masque de protection
un périmètre de sécurité de 19 hectares
est installé depuis qu'un agriculteur
voisin s'est plaint d'irritation aux
yeux et de difficultés respiratoires
du côté des militaires on appelle ça le
principe de précaution pas de quoi
rassurer les riverains pour autant alors
le périmètre a été brièvement ouvert
tout à l'heure à la population et aux
caméras une opération transparence de
l'armée mais pas à moins de 300 mètres
du site s'auto les inquiétudes vis-à-vis
de des gamins qui peuvent changer des
champions et est ce qu'il ya des risques
par la suite
voilà ce que j'ai demandé ils m'ont pas
répondu franchement je fais confiance à
la larme et là jean louis qui nous a
rassurés de ce pot nul donc si je suis
là c'est les humains qui il y as sur
place aucun danger de radioactivité
aucun danger de pollution chimique
il ya des précautions concernant des
éléments surtout composite qui ont été
dispersées sur la zone du crash l'avion
n'était pas armé ce que l'on craint
c'est la dissémination de fibre de
carbone le rafale s'est crashé à 900 km
heure pulvérisé sur des centaines de
mètres pas d'inquiétude répète l'armée
mais précaution toujours toutes les
personnes intervenues sur le site vont
subir un examen des poumons ce crash le
premier d'un rafale s'est produit il
jour causes toujours inconnues le pilote
qui a trouvé la mort selon la justice
l'examen de la boîte noire ne sera pas
connue avant quelques semaines
si tant est qu'elle parle nicolas
sarkozy reçoit ce soir à l'elysée le
président palestinien mahmoud abbas il
est en france pour la conférence
internationale qui s'ouvre demain à
paris une conférence pour soutenir le
futur état palestinien
condi rice et ban ki moon sont également
attendus plusieurs milliards de dollars
seront recueillis un soutien financier
important pour le gouvernement abbas au
bord de la faillite exemple de ses
problèmes budgétaires à l'hôpital
bethléem charles enderlin offs est un
mendiant ppm ou préparent noël qui
espère que les touristes seront plus
nombreux que les années précédentes
grâce à l'aide internationale
la situation économique s'améliore
lentement trop lentement
selon rami qui ramène sa mère appelée
visite à l'hôpital gouvernemental
je n'ai pas trouvé ici tous les
médicaments dont nous avons besoin je
les achetais l'extérieur acridiens on
les rembourse à la pharmacie un peu
chaque coin une situation frustrante
pour les médecins les docteurs y est
rien et mahmoud dirige les services
d'hématologie et d'oncologie
cette patiente souffre d'un cancer
nous lui avons administré un médicament
qui n'agit pas il faudrait un autre
traitement par chimiothérapie
malheureusement ce n'est pas disponible
dans notre hôpital c'est très cher et la
pharmacie du service est plutôt pauvre
si ceux ci celui des camarades et qui
mettait la vie normale
cent vingt six classiques c'est tout on
à la chasse mais le budget de l'autorité
autonome sera épuisé à la fin du mois
mahmoud abbas le président palestinien
il est très important pour nous
d'obtenir une aide économique de manière
claire à la conférence de
lee autrement nous allons à la
catastrophe dès le début janvier comme
l'ensemble de la population
palestinienne médecins et patients
espère que la communauté internationale
sera preuve générosité en irak cette
journée symbolique pour les autorités du
pays l'armée britannique leur a rendu le
contrôle de la province de bassora à un
grand défilé militaire a été organisée à
l'occasion de ce transfert de
responsabilité d'une province clé du sud
de l'irak qui était aux mains des
soldats britanniques depuis mars 2003
l'actualité politique de ce week-end
avec le premier conseil national du
nouveau centre à paris ce mouvement
composé d'anciens udf se sont ralliés à
nicolas sarkozy dans la foulée de la
présidentielle est présidé par le mît de
la défense hervé morin ancien compagnon
de route de françois bayrou et qui a
fait le choix de s'inscrire dans la
majorité présidentielle
une journée marquée par les dernières
actions à visite de mouammar kadhafi en
france le président libyen qui est
arrivé à séville en espagne de réaction
aujourd'hui celle du ministre des
affaires étrangères bernard kouchner et
du premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste françois hollande
alexandre kara les cinq jours de la
visite du colonel kadhafi auront laissé
des traces
vingt-quatre heures après le départ du
guide suprême bernard kouchner sort de
son silence de cette visite il garde un
goût un peu amer
je n'étais pas très à l'aise mais je ne
dis pas qu'il ne fallait pas inviter le
colonel kadhafi mais comme bertrand
delanoë comme bien d'autres membres du
gouvernement et au sommet même de l'état
nous avons été surpris dans ces cinq
jours par le faste et aller et
finalement l'impression qui ressortait
de cette visite peut être aurions nous
dû mais c'est une opinion tout à fait
personnelle ne pas avoir cinq jours de
visite du colonel kadhafi réduire cette
visite à une visite ordinaire et c'est
d'ailleurs sur les conditions de ce
séjour parisien que les critiques des
socialistes sata est-ce qu'il était
surtout pas souhaitable c'est d'avoir la
visite de kadhafi dans les conditions où
elle s'est déroulée
c'est lui qui a mené le jeu ça s'est
terminé dans le folklore le plus
insupportable le plus humiliant pour la
france de le voir kadhafi
et le loup visiter versac avait faire
les chasses présidentielles m'écouter où
était la république quand kadhafi était
dans ses locaux dans ces lieux là dans
ses palais c'est maintenant au tour de
l'espagne de recevoir le colonel kadhafi
il devrait rencontrer demain
rocé luis zapatero le premier ministre
espagnol
l'actualité économique les salariés de
l'usiné de pneumatiques continental à
sarreguemines en moselle vont ils voter
pour le retour à la semaine de 40 heures
et pour le paiement d'une partie de
leurs rtt
c'est en tout cas ce que leur demande
leur direction et cela par référendum
depuis aujourd'hui stéphanie lapointe et
est en kiosque à schmitt urnes bulletins
des assesseurs un bureau de vote comme
les autres ou presque
nous sommes dans l' usine continental de
sarreguemines les 1400 salariés doivent
se prononcer pour ou contre le projet
baptisé donnant gagnant un projet dont
la principale mesure est le retour aux
40 heures hebdomadaires
à la sortie de l'isoloir les ouvriers
sont plutôt fatalistes
je pense qu a pas d'autre choix que de
suivre sinon je pense que si on veut
garder notre travail sur des heures en
plus ça c'est les 35 heures qui sont
elles partent aujourd'hui quand on passe
de 35 à 40 heures ça fait vingt heures
de d'écart et on retrouve passé à la fin
au niveau du salaire qu à sarreguemines
chaque jour 30 mille pneus sont
fabriqués la direction souhaite passer à
32000 une meilleure productivité pour
faire face aux concurrents et s'aligner
sur les autres usines du groupe tout
revenu aux 40 heures les ouvriers
devraient donc travailler 331 jour
contre 325 actuellement on propose donc
une augmentation des revenus de 6% par
an est en fait l'ensemble des heures
supplémentaires qu'on demande de
réaliser seront rémunérés avec les
majorations prévues par la loi il ya une
régression sociale et quand même et la
régression sociale
c'est le fait qu'on
on oblige les gens à venir travailler
des jours fériés le référendum dure
trois jours
les résultats seront donc connus mardi
mais la direction a été clair si le nom
emporte à long terme c'est la survie de
l'usiné qui pourrait être en jeu
les jours passent et noël approche
désormais à grands pas et tout le monde
se pose la question quelles que soient
ses moyens comment faire plaisir autour
de soi les enfants peuvent faire
confiance au père noël mais les adultes
eux doivent se prendre en main dès lors
l'ouverture des magasins le dimanche est
une bénédiction ou un cauchemar au choix
promenade parisienne aujourd'hui avec
sophie brune et emmanuel maurel devant
les vitrines ça piétine pour venir
flâner devant les magasins ce dimanche
il fallait vraiment en avoir envie être
prêt à jouer des coudes et accepter de
se faire un peu bousculée
[ __ ] il s'est fait un plaisir c'est
apporter aussi les festivités conseiller
à la follia les gens mais il ya aussi la
lumière les vitrines l'ambiance à jimmy
chapeau donc c'est pas les père noël
garde donc le sourire
surtout quand ils ont fini de remplir
leurs côtes c'est fini ça fait le 9e pas
qu'on dérange alors bien content que ce
soit terminé encore une semaine
ça m'a poussé dans les temps oui oui on
va essayer quand même avec les enfants
il faut être dans les temps 1
et pendant que les clients cherchent les
derniers cadeaux à placer sous le sapin
chocolat également cinq ans les
commerçants commencent à faire leurs
comptes
il y est on a battu un record de
fréquentation la dû dépasser les 1500
clients ici et l'heure à laquelle on
parle on a déjà dépassé les 800 points
et c'est beaucoup par rapport à
d'habitude
oui c'est beaucoup plus dans l'année ont
fait en moyenne 500 clients par jour
la petite a tant qui va encore se
prolonger pendant huit jours de nombreux
magasins seront à nouveau ouverts
dimanche prochain et dans une semaine
quelques privilégiés trouveront au pied
du sapin des vins de prestige des grands
crus étaient vendus aux enchères ce
week-end à paris des vins exceptionnels
pour amateurs fortunés venus du monde
entier
marie-pierre samitier emmanuel maurel
ce collectionneur a repéré les
bouteilles qu'ils convoitent avant la
vente aux enchères mais qui regarde t-il
précisément sur chaque bouteille
le niveau du vin très important savoir
si la peau trop ou perdu là pour un 1947
d'une superbe dans sa cave il a réussi à
aligner un siècle de château yquem en
bouteille
cette vente est pour lui l'occasion
d'acheter des bouteilles mythiques comme
ceux petrus 1945 je vais voir à quoi ça
mais non on collectionne de son
collectionne les vins comme ont volé sur
les tableaux voilà et donc au regard des
bouteilles
voilà on les garde on ne voit pas on le
boit pas qu'on les imaginait bois autre
chose autre chose mais quoi peut-être
boire at-il sans être iconoclaste cette
belle caisse de château latour 1971
en tout cas il ne boira pas ces grandes
dames dont les prix vont s'envoler comme
ce cheval blanc c'est romanée conti ou
ceux richebourg d'henri juillet 1978 une
toute petite production alors la
bouteille atteindra 10 mille euros 6000
bouteilles cette ville bouteille au
niveau mondial c'est rien donc ça
explique parfaitement ses prix
astronomiques une demande extrêmement
forte
car les clientèles fortunées des états
unis de chine ou de russie ont dépêché
leurs représentants une fois de plus
dans cette vente aux enchères pour
s'offrir ces bouteilles prestigieuse
elle échappe alors aux acheteurs
traditionnels qui assistent impuissants
à l'envolée des prix hors média 4000
euros + repas centrale
nous allons commencer à 2500 la
bouteille une vente d'un montant record
de 2 millions d'euros pour l'une des
plus belles enchères de vins de la nuit
de l'eau maintenant montpellier
inaugurée ce week-end son nouvel
aquarium l'un des plus grands d'europe
avec ses dizaines de milliers de
poissons et d'animaux marins
quant aux visiteurs ils ont été en
quelque sorte pris dans une tempête en
mer vous allez le voir plus vrai que
nature
hélène verne parce qu'elles pensent un
message de détresse vient d'être lancée
sans réponse les vagues se succèdent et
se brisent sur la coque du cargo à son
bord une trentaine de visiteurs plongée
au coeur de la tourmente
je me tiens à baby roi des grosses
vagues une tempête factice dans un avis
reconstitué c'est l'une des attractions
phares du nouvel aquarium de montpellier
et cette immersion débute dès le hall
d'entrée ce qu'on a voulu se faire en
sorte que lorsqu'on imagine l'aquarium
s'est pas simplement une succession de
bassins et c'est pas seulement les
poissons qui sont mises en scène c'est
aussi une public
un voyageur invités à découvrir toutes
les mers du monde ici une quinzaine de
requins le taureau le gris règne sur ce
bassin l'un des plus vastes d'europe
comme un balcon sur l'océan
on n'arrive pas à analyser ce qu'on
ressent mais on a l'impression d'être
dedans et de les voir vivre de les voir
bouger
en général on les voit dans des bassins
qui font très artificielle alors que là
on a l'impression que c'est un milieu
complètement naturel et que
on se retrouve devant la réalité deux
heures de parcours à la rencontre de 30
mille poissons et animaux aquatiques 90%
d'entre eux sont nés en captivité on est
là aussi pour inciter à la conservation
inciter à à ce que les gens changent de
change de comportement ou et des
comportements beaucoup plus respectueux
de l'environnement
en bout de route se voyait jours a
nécessité quatre années de recherches et
28 millions d'euros d'investissement il
reste aujourd'hui elle rentabiliser la
page sports de cette fin de week-end
avec d'abord les résultats de la 18e
journée de liga en football avant la
dernière rencontre de ce soir qui
opposera bordeaux à marseille strasbourg
a fait match nul à domicile face à nancy
qui garde la deuxième place du
championnat
coup de projecteur maintenant sur laure
manaudou la nageuse française qui
suscite toujours toutes les passions et
la championne était une nouvelle fois au
rendez-vous ce week-end en hongrie lors
du championnat d'europe trois médailles
deux en or et une en argent des succès
et leur monde sa vie qui ressemble
parfois à une sitcom christophe tortora
et frédéric bazire
le sourire de laure manaudou masque mal
sa déception avec une médaille d'argent
pour conclure ces championnats d'europe
l'or a passé un mauvais dimanche dans
l'épreuve du 200 m nage libre la
française s'est fait dépasser dans la
dernière ligne droite
l'explication se trouve peut-être en
dehors du bassin jusqu'ici leur croiser
son ancien fiancé l'italien luca marine
lors des points presse sans un regard
mais ce matin juste avant sa demi-finale
il est venu lui parler et l'explication
a été houleuse l'orgie aurait rendu une
bague devant d'autres nageurs de
l'équipe italienne
un affront qui a du mal à passer on est
loin des tendres baisers échangés au
bord de l'eau cet été la page italienne
est désormais refermée et avoir le
journal du dimanche lors s'affiche
désormais avec un autre nageur français
mais le bilan sportif de ces
championnats est tout même excellent
l'or revient de hongrie avec deux titres
de championne d'europe sur 100 m dos et
sur 400 m elle reste invaincue sur cette
distance depuis les jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004
les entraîneurs changent son talent
reste hors norme
les colères de philippe lucas l'escapade
en italie font désormais partie des
souvenirs
nicolas son jeune frère a depuis trois
mois la responsabilité de son
entraînement
un travail et une vie de famille qui
semble lui convenir
l'or a une nouvelle fois ce week-end
c'est retentir la marseillaise
un hymne qu'elle espère bien entendre
cet été aussi à pékin
et laure manaudou est avec nous bonsoir
lors merci d'être avec nous ce soir
tout d'abord est ce que vous êtes
satisfaite de ce week-end en or et en
argent
satisfaite
on va dire ça comme ça mais c'est vrai
que j'ai eu une petite déception
aujourd'hui parce que j'aurais préféré
finir première mais ça s'est plutôt bien
passé donc ça va est ce qu'on peut dire
que la collaboration avec votre frère
vous savez qu'on a beaucoup écrit
là-dessus ça se passe bien finalement
ouais ça se passe bien on a pu voir même
si je suis arrivée première hier j'ai
quand même fait un montant aux 400 g
j'ai fait un bon temps au 100 dos donc
ça marche très bien et tous les gens
qu'on critiquait je pense que maintenant
ils ont plus rien à dire alors vous avez
sourire également avec votre ancien
entraîneur philippe lucas est ce que les
liens sont en quelque sorte normalisé
maintenant je pense pas ou on s'attend
toujours bien donc
après c'est plus mon entraîneur donc
c'est plus facile mais je pense que
ouais c'est ça c'est bien rangé alors
l'objectif maintenant ce sont les jeux
olympiques mais beaucoup de compet cette
année encore donc je vais me concentrer
je vais prendre mon temps et ouais c'est
laisser bien sûr les jeux olympiques
mais ces championnats d'europe donc va
faire petit à petit et bien se
concentrer pour pour essayer de gagner
dans mes courses
vous avez eu cet après midi une
altercation je crois avec votre ancien
petit ami on en a parlé
selon les dépêches afp juste avant votre
série est ce que c'est un incident qui
vous a déstabilisé ou pas voyez déjà ce
monde que courant
donc voilà non mais c'est quelque chose
il faut qu' il faut savoir faire la part
des choses quand on est dans sa dans sa
course et quand on est concentrés donc
j'ai pas envie de parler de ça parce que
c'est
et ça s'est mal passé donc voilà j'ai
pas envie d'en parler bon ben alors on
vous suivra dans le bassin bientôt merci
laure manaudou et encore bravo pour la
compétition ils interviewent donc
réalisé il ya quelques instants
le cinéma avec je suis une légende le
nouveau film dans lequel vous pourrez
retrouver mercredi will smith dans les
salles un film qui devrait réjouir les
fans de science fiction car il est
l'adaptation d'un roman qui a inspiré
toute une génération d'auteurs et de
réalisateurs un nouveau défi pour l'un
des acteurs les plus doués de sa
génération will smith est avec nous mais
avant d'en parler avec lui y voyons à
quoi ressemble cette nouvelle
performance
emmanuel lambert new york 2012
la vie s'est brutalement arrêté trois
ans plus tôt une terrible épidémie a
frappé le monde par tous les moyens
la population tente de fuir la mort est
imminente
coulibaly
aujourd'hui robert neville pense être le
dernier homme l'unique survivant dans un
manhattan où la nature a repris le
contrôle
vous savez où il s'agit c'est un jeu
d'acteur extrêmement variés il vous fait
pitié il vous inspire la peur il fait
rire vous provoque des larmes et à
chaque scène on est toujours crédible
le problème vous l'imaginez bien c'est
que will smith n'est pas tout seul
ceux qui ne sont pas morts mais presque
en tout les nuits de new york et ils ont
repéré
cette histoire est issu d'un grand roman
de science-fiction des années 50
l'inspiration un film d'horreur mythique
quand j'étais adolescent j'ai vu le film
dracula avec bela lugosi et je me suis
dit si un vampire faire peur imaginons
linverse un seul homme et un monde
rempli de vampire ça ça fait vraiment
peur tourné en sept mois
je suis une légende a bien failli en
rester une à tout jamais ce film on en
parle depuis 1994
mel gibson schwazenegger tom cruise
finalement c'est will smith qui a été
choisi il vous fera explorer l'esprit
humain ou ce qu'il en reste après
l'apocalypse
effrayant et on a appris aujourd'hui que
le film qui vient de sortir aux états
unis ce vendredi est déjà en train de
battre tous les records d'entrées dans
les salles bonsoir oui smith merci
d'être avec nous ce soir en direct sur
ce plateau
j'imagine que ça doit vous faire plaisir
lorsque vous apprenez les premiers
chiffres du box office
oui bien sûr c'est fantastique
écoutez c'est un projet que j'adore
depuis au moins dix ans et j'ai toujours
essayé de comprendre de trouver un moyen
de le monter c'est le concept qu'on
avait toujours cette parole de se
concentrer sur une petite histoire là
l'histoire d'un seul personnage qui dans
la psychologie des crade et c'est tout
enveloppé vraiment dans un grand film
quelle expérience que ce rôle de robert
neville dans cette ville de new york
comment vous avez fait pour tourner ces
séquences de new york vide comme ça à ta
l'aube
new york les new yorkais vous savez il
n'était pas très content parce que il a
fallu complètement bloqué la 5e avenue à
main à lundi matin à 8h du matin donc
vraiment ce qu'on veut à l'écran c'est
magnifique mais les automobilistes
étaient pas contents du tout durant de
longues minutes au début du film vous
retrouvez seul avec le chien vous parler
avoue même ça roule vraiment atypique
pour vous qu'on voit souvent dans
l'action oui oui ce que l'on a essayé de
faire c'est de prendre la démarche
suivante celle vraiment d'akiva goldsman
qui est le scénariste et richard
matheson aussi lorsque l'on a essayé de
faire c'est de se concentrer sur lui
c'est vraiment un personnage un
archétype et c'est c'est très difficile
à faire parce que quand on a autant le
budget tous les effets spéciaux il faut
vraiment tout éliminer c'est vraiment de
se concentrer seulement sur le
personnage seul au milieu new york avec
tout le bruit autour ça a été difficile
vraiment de se concentrer sur sept alors
ses personnages il ya vraiment
deux univers dans sims cet univers de
réflexion venait d'aborder et puis il ya
un univers assez effrayant c'est quand
même limite à film d'horreur parfois en
tout cas moi j'ai eu très peur vous le
dis sincèrement vous savez que l'on a
voulu faire c'est de créer cet espace où
il ya des éléments de films d'horreur de
films d'action aussi des moments qui
sont très comique est vraiment ne pas
s'engager à un seul genre et pour
essayer vraiment créer un film qui
couvre l'ensemble de la gamme etc pour
les jeunes je 7 à 77 ans et les plus
âgés c'est pas la première fois qu'on
vient sur cette fin du monde l'amérique
dans ses films revient assez souvent là
dessus c'est quelque chose qui est
particulier à l'amérique vous avez peur
de cette fin du monde ou à titre
personnel vous savez et je crois que il
y a une idée vraiment profonde sanou au
fond nous tous c'est la peur de ce qui
va se passer
qu'est ce qu'il y aura à l'avenir le ski
est dans les ténèbres ce que l'on ne
connaît pas ce qui vais vraiment ce qui
nous attend et c'est un concept qui se
prête tout particulièrement aux
spectaculaires aux effets spéciaux c'est
lé film de roland emmerich par exemple
je ne sais pas comment l'appeler ici ce
film vraiment l'apocalypse la fin des
temps armageddon armageddon oui
armageddon c'est ça toutes ces idées ça
vraiment vraiment ça se prête à un
cinéma très puissant avec des images qui
parlent vraiment qui montre toutes les
possibilités de ce que l'on peut voir
qu'il peut exploiter tout ce que l'on
peut faire maintenant dans le cinéma
avec les effets spéciaux
alors où elles subissent vous avez du
succès au cinéma une vie de famille
équilibrée vos enfants sont très doués
on les a déjà vus au cinéma en france on
appelle ça avoir la baraka
tout marche pour vous finalement oui
tout va extrêmement bien pour moi à
l'heure actuelle ça va très bien
je viens de parler à ma femme et c'est
vrai que ça a été le premier grand week
end pour un de mes films mais c'est je
me suis vraiment démener pour ce film
j'ai travaillé extrêmement dur
j'avais l'impression d'être un sportif
parce que en tant qu'acteur je me
développe tous les jours j'ai vraiment
l'occasion de travailler avec des
réalisateurs exceptionnel et pour moi
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'à
qu'éthique donc c'est vraiment je suis
vraiment excité par tout ce qui pourra
se passer leurs nerfs
on vous aime beaucoup quand est ce qu
hollywood vous donne un oscar à écouter
mais tant que le public va voir les
films est temps qu'ils payent leur
ticket je peux attend aussi longtemps
que je veux merci beaucoup et smith
juste une dernière question c'est vous
qui jouait qui fait le swin golf sur
cette aile d'avion voilà regarder vers
l'ouest c'est tout moi aucun effet
spécial du coc oui les boules alors
bravo en tout cas merci beaucoup je suis
une légende c'est à suivre à partir de 2
mercredi c'est un très très bon film et
comme chaque dimanche nous faisons le
point sur le box office des sorties
cinéma de la semaine en france entre
bignona film d'animation avec la voix de
gad elmaleh puis le très beau le renard
et l'enfant autre film familial nexity
de djamel bensalah avec les enfants
qu'aux médias à la fiche
enfin la comédie si c'était lié avec
carole bouquet et marc lavoine will
smith juste il ya une présentation du
film demain je crois à paris c'est ça à
la paramount
oui oui tout à fait c'est l'avant
première demain je suis vraiment excité
tout le monde va venir vous venez tout
le monde on va s'éclater vient vous voir
merci et un moment fermé journal je vous
rappelle l'une des principales
informations
alors que le froid s'est installé sur
l'ensemble du pays la polémique en entre
eux
la ministre du logement et les enfants
de don quichotte sur le dossier des sans
abri
le premier ministre françois fillon
recevra les associations les plus
directement impliqués dans la suivi des
sdf et cela dès ce mardi
voilà pour l'actualité de ce dimanche
merci de nous avoir suivis dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinez
l'inter 5 ans née ma créance de sang
avec clint eastwood vous retrouvez dès
demain pour l'information élise lucet à
13h et david pujadas à 20h passé une
très belle soirée et de belles fêtes de
fin d'année à très bientôt
au revoir
l'info en continu c'est aussi sur france
2 point fr
des mineurs